make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today's episode of our what-if series is
going to be a little bit different
because instead of looking and creating
our own hypothetical situations in comic
books we're going to be moving over to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
creating our own story there and today
we're going to ask and answer the
question what if Thor's hammer Mjolnir
had not been destroyed
prior to Avengers infinity war and so
let's start out by recapping the status
of Thor immediately prior to Infinity
Ward now as most of you guys know
infinity war starts out immediately
after the events of Thor Ragnarok and as
we saw at the beginning of the film
Thor's hammer had been destroyed by
hella prior to Sardar being unleashed
and essentially bringing about the end
of Asgard which of course we saw at the
end of the movie now Thor Loki Hulk and
a surviving ass guardians get on a
spaceship to escape Ragnarok and
sometimes shortly thereafter their ship
is attacked by Thanos and that's where
infinity war picks up with Thanos coming
onboard Thor ship and of course Thor is
without his signature weapon mule nerve
and so basically at this point we have
to ask what having y'all near have made
a difference to what happened in the
movie and in my opinion the answer to
that is an emphatic no what we do know
is that between the mid-credits scene
and Ragnarok in the beginning of
infinity war Thanos and the Black Order
have intercepted Thor's ship and somehow
incapacitated Thor because he has been
completely subdued by the time infinity
war starts we don't see exactly how this
happens but I feel comfortable saying
that Mjolnir wouldn't have made a
difference because at this point Thanos
has acquired the power stone and is able
to single-handedly beat the Hulk so
badly that he basically quit right he
didn't want to come out again and so
taking on Thor even with Mjolnir
wouldn't be much of a challenge for
Thanos and furthermore later on Thanos
without any Infinity stones is able to
handle Thor wielding both Mjolnir and
Stormbreaker so I don't really see
Mjolnir making any difference here so
Thor story arc from here goes the same
way as it always did he's basically
adrift in space until he's rescued by
the guardians of the galaxy where our
story would start to diverge from the
movie is that with Milner
still in his possession Thor likely
would not need to go to Nadav Alire so
that the dwarf III could Forge
Stormbreaker forth while Stormbreaker is
depicted in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as being a superior weapon to
Mjolnir I think it would be unlikely
that if Thor still had a weapon as
powerful as Mjolnir that he would waste
the time it took to make the journey
northward himself through the physically
torturous process
of starting the forge unless he was in
desperate need of a weapon and so how
does that change things well without for
rocket and Groot needing to go to Nadav
earlier the Guardians team doesn't have
to split up which means that they'll be
at full strength when they encounter
Thanos for the first time now if you'll
recall what happens is that the
Guardians think they're encountering
Thanos in the collectors Museum and are
about to kill the collector but it turns
out that was a ruse designed to draw
Gamora to Thanos so he could take her to
four Mir in order to exchange her soul
for the soul stone now by this time
Thanos is in possession of the reality
stone which he uses to defeat the
guardians in rapid succession before
securing Gamora and this is another
instance where he would ask would Thor
be here make a difference and again I
think the answer is No although Thor is
unquestionably more powerful than any of
the guardians he is still probably not
going to be enough to tilt the battle in
the heroes favor especially with Thanos
in possession of three Infinity stones
and so I think vanos is still going to
be able to capture Gamora and take her
to war mirror and sacrifice her to
obtain the soul stone the circumstance
just would have happened a little bit
differently now where I do think Thor
could have made a big difference is on
Titan so this is where the guardians
meet up with Iron Man spider-man and
Doctor Strange and this group is almost
able to get the Infinity Gauntlet from
Thanos using mantises ability to
mentally subdue him while spider-man and
Iron Man try to pry the gauntlet from
Thanos his hand which takes them so long
that Peter quill finds out that Gamora
has been sacrificed and screws
everything up by breaking mantises
control over the nose I said it I'll
always say it you'll never hear me
believe that I'm wrong about this I am
right about this star-lord Peter quill
like basically killed half the universe
it's because of him that half the
universe Thoth or should have been
moping around Thor should have been like
nah this wouldn't be a problem if it
hadn't been for star-lord but I can't
punch him because he got dusted so the
best I can do is mope but regardless
Thor is vastly stronger than both iron
man and spider-man put together so it's
almost certain that he would have been
able to get the gauntlet from Thanos his
grasp fairly easily and I'm not
overstating things when I say that this
changes everything
once the gauntlets removed Doctor
Strange creates a portal back to earth
with his sling ring and then since
spider-man through with the gauntlet
from there the guardians Avengers and
Doctor Strange try to battle Thanos who
by now has broken free of mantises
influence the heroes are able to gain
the upper hand but Thanos is able to
make it back to his ship and escape the
heroes
back to earth to regroup before Thanos
is inevitable attempt to regain the
Infinity Gauntlet now as these events
unfold on Titan back on earth a battle
is raging in Wakanda it's Thanos forces
try and retrieve the mine stone this
house with envisions head and so in the
movie this is the big climactic battle
scene of infinity war but more
importantly it's where the snap happens
it wipes out half the universe's
population because of star-lord but
without the rest of the stones vanos
decides to call off his attack and wait
for a more strategic time to invade the
earth
since now pressing on and procuring the
mine stone is too risky since now the
Avengers possess all the stones and the
gauntlet and star Lords not being an
idiot and so when the Avengers and the
guardians reunite on earth they begin
debating what to do about the Infinity
stone but determined that it would be
beyond their capability without
assembling the gauntlet and using the
stones to destroy themselves and so the
plan they come up with is that the
stones will be separated and guarded by
a different member of the team sure he
separates the mind stone from vision and
so it is stored within a highly secure
vault augmented by the most advanced
wakandan technology ant-man shrinks down
and hides the reality stone within the
quantum realm Thor takes the space stone
Danu Asgard Nick Fury takes the Power
Stone to a secret shield facility and
summons Captain Marvel to take the soul
stone to the far reaches of space with
her finally Doctor Strange takes the
time stone within a pocket dimension he
created and so instead of the whole time
travel story with the Avengers trying to
procure the stones we get them trying to
secure the stones as they prepare for
Thanos invasion and so as expected
Thanos brings the entirety of his forces
to earth in attempt to reunite the stone
and this plays out fairly similarly to
what we saw at the end of end game with
Oliver's heroes uniting to repel Thanos
as forces and so we still get the
massive battle scene and in that big
battle scene there are definitely going
to be some casualties and in this way I
think that in this instance we have a
bit more gravitas with the story playing
out this way then what we saw in the
actual movie where you had all the super
emotional deaths at the end of infinity
war only for all of them to essentially
be undone and in-game but during the
battle Thanos forces unfortunately take
out vision Hawkeye and most notably
Captain America who dies at the hands of
Thanos without Mjolnir to aid him in
that battle since Thor still has it
however there are victories for the
heroes as well as Thor manages to strike
a killing blow to Corvus glaive with
Mjolnir a Koi a impales Proxima midnight
the Hulk takes out Coll of
and after a hard-fought battle and
star-lord doesn't make any stupid
choices now in the chaos Thanos is
poised to strike down Pepper Potts who's
dawn the rescue armored Iron Man is
spider-man intervene and begin battling
Thanos and save peppers life for the
moment however things quickly go south
as Thanos gains the upper hand now just
as Thanos is about to deliver a fatal
blow to spider-man Tony Stark
throws himself in front of Thanos his
blade in an act of self-sacrifice rally
by twenties death
The Avengers make a final push but
Thanos forces are too numerous for them
to take out until Captain Marvel
responds to a distress call put out by
Nick Fury and returns to earth now the
added firepower that she provides gives
earth forces the necessary strength
needed to wipe out the rest of Thanos
forces and so that just leaves the issue
of Thanos himself and taking him out is
no small feat even without any of the
Infinity stones keeping in mind the heat
was without them for most of the battle
in endgame and was still able to defeat
nearly everyone who tried to engage him
in battle the notable exception of
course being the Scarlet Witch who's
often depicted as being insanely
powerful in our comic appearances but we
haven't really gotten to see her on her
powers and full display you know up
until endgame what she literally uses
her magical powers to seemingly begin
tearing him apart until she's
interrupted by some of his minions but
with Thanos his forces neutralized this
paves the way for Scarlet Witch to
channel all of her anger over the loss
of vision and to have her moment as the
hero that finally takes down Thanos once
and for all and so it was crazy to think
that just by having taken away the
destruction of Mjolnir from thor
ragnarok how much of the plot of
infinity war in endgame would completely
change I mean sure you end up in pretty
much the same place with Thanos being
defeated and Tony Stark dead but there
wasn't really a way around that since of
course the good guys basically end up
winning and Robert Downey jr. was ready
to leave the franchise although as I
understand it he's ready to come back
but you would eliminate the snap and a
five-year period after it which would
drastically change the landscape of the
movie you don't get Lebowski Thor which
would admittedly be a detriment to the
multitude of fans that like the
character because he was awesome right
like the Thor abides and Black Widow
doesn't have to sacrifice herself to get
the soul stone
so her solo movie can actually be a
sequel instead of a prequel which I
think would generate a lot more interest
or as much interest as a Black Widow
movie can generate and then you
eliminate the time-travel plot from
needing to exist and honestly although
it gives us some cool
anytime you bring time travel into the
narrative things have a tendency to get
overly messy and sometimes convoluted
honesty of things that played out this
way you could possibly streamline
everything into a single film or just
aloud the battle at the end to dominate
the screen time for endgame the biggest
negative though would be that instead of
giving Steve Rogers the happy ending of
going back in time and living out a full
life with Peggy Carter in this version
of the story he dies and so facially
would end on even more of a down note
than it already did but at the end of
the day we still need to provide a way
for Chris Evans to exit the franchise as
well what that means said guys let me
know what you guys think about this
about taking the what-if stories from
comments that we make up and then also
extending it to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and making up our own stories
for how things would have played out
differently in the MCU because we have
all kinds of ideas right like that's the
benefit of making up our what-if stories
we can do whatever we want but we have
being said guys we're doing this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain and make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you guys later peace
[Music]
you